how's it going everybody gets warned
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talked about everything
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today we have some excellent
news as San Diego comic-con has
officially announced its dates now of
course as everybody knows San Diego
comic-con is pretty much the biggest
event of the year for us it's where we
get a ton of information not just about
Marvel but all things in general Star
Wars and DC it really is just a huge
convention last year we got the entire
Marvel phase 4 slate revealed to us plus
Kevin Feige mentioned the x-men and the
Fantastic Four so everyone was really
looking forward to this year but
unfortunately due to the coronavirus
they had to cancel it in person they are
now doing San Diego comic-con at home so
now we have the official dates for San
Diego comic-con at home Steve Weintraub
from Collider has tweeted breaking San
Diego comic-con at home will be held on
the same dates as the previously
canceled Comic Con July 22nd through
July 26th and will be free they're
promising panels and presentations about
comics gaming television film and a wide
variety of topics from publishers
studios and more now this is very
exciting but let's talk about what we
can expect from marvel at San Diego
comic-con at home obviously there's a
lot of hope that we're going to get some
decent reveals specifically regarding
the trailers for the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier and the Wanda vision
series and although we're very hopeful
that we'll get these trailers we
shouldn't get our expectations too high
because it sounds like San Diego Comic
Con at home is going to be kind of like
WonderCon online which was a really big
disappointment to a lot of people and
there weren't really any reveals or
releases from Marvel Studios in that and
in fact although Comic Con at home is
announced it's not yet 100% confirmed
that Marvel will have a panel in fact
they could decide to do their own panel
online separate from comic-con at home
but this is the big Comic Con and no
doubt Marvel was going to appear in Hall
age at San Diego Comic Con if the
coronavirus wouldn't have canceled it so
stay tuned I'll report any and all
things that I hear about Marvel Studios
at Comic Con at home and in the meantime
you can tune in on July 22nd through
July 26 for free and see what they have
to offer be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you don't miss out on any
updates about comic
at home and so you can enter this week's
giveaway to win a Deadpool Funko pop be
sure to like this video and for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof